security remains high the day after the
election with thousands of troops
deployed across the country despite
dozens of minor attacks many afghans
expressed relief that polling day had
passed off without any major incidents
we're so happy that yesterday's election
took place in a peaceful environment
there was good security around the
country and everywhere was peaceful
people went to the polling stations with
a lot of hope despite all the threats
they took part to choose their future
leader
turnout exceeded expectations and there
were reports of ballot paper shortages
in some areas
an estimated 7 million of the 12 million
eligible voters participated in the poll
in a televised address shortly after
polling stations closed outgoing
president hamid kazai thanked people for
the high turnout and praised them for
defying terrorist threats to come out
and vote
he described the election as a step
forward and a success for the country
despite the positive mood the three
front runners have complained of
possible fraud no candidate is expected
to receive an overall majority though
many in afghanistan want to avoid a
runoff vote
we want the election finalized in the
first round because the people
government and economy are very weak a
second round would challenge the
security forces
but a runoff seems to be a foregone
conclusion and would take place at the
end of may